welcome to a new project camp update so
we basically bought a piece of land and
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living
and let's see how this is going to go
and in the previous updates you've seen
us preparing the ground so the
containers can come
and in this video i'm going to share a
little bit the problems and challenges
we currently have because we have to
wait for the containers anyway
and actually i also noticed something
here in portugal i also didn't know
it can actually get quite cold
especially in a van
so this is my best friend around here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chilly day
so it's actually gotten quite cold in
here and it's not ideal in a van
and the solar needs some defrosting but
it does create
beautiful landscapes and the grass is
crispy and white
and the trees give a christmas feeling
very cool actually to see the landscape
like this
but it does create a few problems what's
going on
it's for matia it's from mattia
look this is a block of ice this is a
block of ice
look pumpy
one of the best this made my life for
a couple of months i was just flying and
it's basically a water pump
ice and you just press there and then
you have like running water in your van
no dishwashing not made for portugal
extreme conditions and you just press
there and wait
wait look like glacier water we have a
bit of ice here
coming out
not working
and overall the nights are cold but
during the day it gets warmed up by the
sun and the temperature is actually
super nice
and you can see everything defrosting
like here everything is green except the
shadow that is still
warming up
so i want to let you guys know a little
bit the problems or
challenges we currently have here and
also answer a few questions i often
see popping up on discord and youtube
so i've been walking around a bit found
this uh
cute abandoned house so yeah
let's do a problem talk and q a
you find so many of these abandoned
structures
where you have like the countryside area
and then an old ruin renovated at some
point
then i don't know neglected or abandoned
but if you're around here it really
feels like
the whole countryside is slowly
i don't know going away full of old
people almost
no young people probably when they pass
away
it's all gonna be like this just
abandoned buildings
alright so here are our challenges
first one i would say is cleaning the
road we just need to have the road
cleaned so the container can come
and the container has a lot of resources
we need
because living in a van the whole time
is quite minimal
but yeah it's just a road to be cleaned
and
the municipality should do this but
we've been waiting for like two months
talk with the president to the
assistants send them a letter visit the
municipality
and they all say it will happen next
week but then i don't know it's locked
down then it's christmas then it's cold
then i don't know it just takes forever
which in a way is not a super big
problem because uh
it's just a container we could go
without the container but they kind of
scare me for our second problem
which is uh we need to get an address
and we need an address for a few reasons
one is more practical stuff that i can
finally set up a portuguese bank account
but also it depends on a few services
for instance if we want to get
electricity we cannot start the process
of getting electricity
because we first need to have an address
that they have a location where they can
even come
or if you want internet they need to
know what is your address
so a lot of stuff is blocked because we
don't have an address
and that has already been set in motion
as well a few months ago
but seeing how long it takes to clean a
road
which is done in like a day i'm i'm
scared
how long the other is going to take
yeah which also directly affects problem
3 electricity
so the land had a few electricity poles
on there so
when we bought the land we asked like
hey have you had do we have electricity
and they said yeah it's easy
just call the company and they make it
so we called the company and then
they said yeah we can do it if you have
electricity pull
but then you start really diving into it
and then they realized oh you also need
to have a structure on there
i also need to have a permit to get
actually electricity i also need to have
a certified electrician
so it's actually not that easy at all so
now i'm very much
questioning whether we should go for
really connecting to the grid
or going straight to solar which is way
more complex to do
with our workspace three-phase having
enough battery
especially in the winter when you have
less solar
so i don't know to be honest it seems
like quite a expensive undertaking
and also quite challenging topic to do
and to set up
uh that big so for us it was always more
like a long-term thing like nice we have
grit we can start with that and slowly
phase it out
and educate ourselves more on the topic
of of grit electricity
so yeah but maybe now it needs to be
accelerated because processes move so
slow
i don't know to be honest what what what
how it would go maybe i know it's more
clear within a month
uh all right so question question i
often get what's your plan there
uh i think the real honest questions is
don't really know
and also didn't really plan that much to
be honest
we know this piece of land gives us a
bit of freedom to experiment
but up until now the focus has also
really been very much to just get the
basics there make sure we have an
address container electricity
and then we can plan for the next phase
because i also don't really want to plan
yet if i depend a lot on uh things like
municipality
i mean which scare me because then you
plan let's do
stuff in summer and then i don't know we
cannot but yeah in general i would say
the rough plan would be
to first get the shared infrastructure
in place like a work space in the
kitchen
and then start working more on houses
but it still feels like
kind of far away before we actually
start that process
at the moment not that much we have a
lot of people that want to join from
external like outside people but also
within our own team
but it really feels like there's not
that much to do a lot of processes is
just waiting for a municipality
and well you can wait with 10 people but
it doesn't really make sense
so mainly it's now just me matia drops
by every now and then because in the
porto
and krita is here as well she mainly
starts portuguese and can do all the
talks with the
presidents and municipalities um and
besides that
yeah it's not that much going on yet i
think once we have those basics here
we could really start setting up a team
and make the next
phase
so not really figured that part out the
land was bought
by some money we had and some loan from
friends and family
which was super nice actually that they
helped out
but for the long term we don't really
have a plan for that yet
uh but up until now the costs have also
been low
i mean uh because we're not really
building anything i think once we start
planning for the next phase
we really not a problem
full sd cards
um but i think once we start planning
phase two when we need to get maybe for
instance installing solar
or really building the workspace and
building some proper infrastructure i
think that's when we seriously need to
look into it
so if you have any tips or tricks let me
know
at the moment not yet because yeah we're
still waiting for the basics to even be
set up
and if you would come now you can
come and sit next to me on a chair and
wait
so yeah wouldn't recommend that
at the moment i would say wake up in a
cold van
maybe do some work on the land maybe do
some filming
and some talks with the municipality
some days i spend on the land but if
it's really bad weather
or like raining all day i often go to
santa como dao as well where i have some
internet
get a nice breath and then yeah do there
so it's a bit of a combination of those
two i think also
yeah continuing the digital work and
doing the physical work in the land
well actually i don't know if you can
help with this but one thing i always
wanted to do is making more time-lapse i
think they're really cool to make
it's really beautiful also to see the
land evolving over time
but i only have one camera it's not
waterproof and sometimes i just want to
leave the time lapse for a day or
something
so i was actually thinking of maybe
asking you guys but maybe i'll do it in
a proper
video at some point to ask if you have
some old cameras laying around maybe a
gopro or stuff you don't need
and i can all hook them up so we have
more ways of capturing what's going on
in the land
one thing that's also on the list is to
make like a weather box
that measures the wind but also the
humidity the amount of sun
the amount of rain that there falls i
mean a lot of this information you can
find on the internet but it's still kind
of general
and i would be very curious to have them
on a few places on the land where we can
really measure and keep track of it
ourselves
there are a lot of open source adreno
projects actually on this
but uh i don't know i need to dive into
it and
it's kind of hard without my tools but
if this container would arrive
it's still kind of hard to even order
components because we don't have this
post office and even if we have an
address
it doesn't have a mailbox or anything so
i don't know this stuff is a bit
challenging to do around here
so maybe within the community people are
interested in this topic
and i don't know i would be very happy
to install them here and keep track of
it
all right so that was it that was the
problems right here
if you have more questions let me know
in the comments or go to discord
to to hang out thanks for watching i
think i'm gonna get home it's gonna get
very chilly
alright see you guys next